ci sono persone che riescono a fare del
loro della loro passione un lavoro altre
che riescono a vivere il loro lavoro con
passione e poi ci sono persone che
semplicemente hanno una passione è un
lavoro e sembra che queste due cose non
si tocchino mai non si incrocino sembra
ma che cosa potrebbe accadere se invece
questi due mondi si incrociassero si
contaminassero consapevolmente
io ho passato lunghi periodi della mia
vita nell'area umida delle piscine ben
saprete che magari la mia passione sia
il nuoto
io ho paura persino dell'acqua alta in
realtà accompagnavo mia figlia agli
allenamenti e alle gare di nuoto
sincronizzato e nelle lunghe attese
leggevo questa sì una mia grande
passione nel 2012
mi capitò di leggere l'intervista a
christine lagarde che aveva rilasciato
al settimanale stern perché da poco era
stata nominata prima donna a capo del
fondo monetario internazionale donna
elegante di charme avvocato d'affari già
ministro dell'economia in francia madre
di due figli sportiva una di quelle
donne che già mentre le gt coeli ma come
fa a far tutto
come fa a reggere certe pressioni e poi
nell'intervista una frase rivelatrice
per lei
medaglia di bronzo ai campionati
nazionali in francia di nuoto
sincronizzato nel 73 il nuoto
sincronizzato era stato fondamentale mi
aveva insegnato capacità di resistenza e
tenuta quando sei sotto pressione di
controlli
stringi i denti e sorridi mi aveva
colpito quelle parole io conoscevo il
nuoto sincronizzato per via di mia
figlia e conosco il lavoro nelle
organizzazioni fu facile per me trovare
una connessione tra alcuni aspetti della
pratica del nuoto sincronizzato e alcuni
aspetti
del mondo del lavoro per esempio la
capacità di spezzare un grande macro
obiettivo in tanti piccoli step
d'allenare con tenacia la capacità di
rispecchiarsi per trovare la sincronia
con la squadra
la capacità di tenere il feedback
dell'istruttore insomma è da lì che ho
cominciato a trovare sempre più
connessioni tra il mondo del lavoro e le
attività extra lavorative le passioni
che guidano le nostre vite ogni giorno e
questo è quello che vi racconterò oggi
cioè che cosa potrebbe accadere quando
scegliamo consapevolmente di portare le
nostre passioni all'interno del mondo
del lavoro
cosa possono avere in comune con la
christine lagarde i fratelli wright
considerati gli inventori del volo e art
fry da tutti ritenuto l'inventore dei
posti beh
entrambi hanno trovato l'idea distintiva
per l'attività lavorativa che stavano
seguendo a partire da una loro passione
personale per i fratelli wright
sull'osservazione della natura loro
amanti della vita all'aria aperta si
trovarono ad osservare il volo dei
grifoni in una sorta di avvoltoi che
vivono in nord america e fu grazie a
questo che scoprirono in che modo far
virare l'aereo cioè avrebbero dovuto
creare un meccanismo in grado di far
inclinare velato il velivolo esattamente
come di lato si inclinano gli uccelli in
volo per art fa invece fu cruciale la
sua passione per il canto nel coro della
chiesa
lui lavorava alla iii n è un suo collega
già diversi anni prima alla ricerca di
un adesivo molto più potente aveva
scoperto per caso
l'adesivo dei post it ma né lui nella 3m
trovarono un'applicazione finché sei
anni dopo nel 74 mentre cantava nel coro
della chiesa
il nostro art fry ebbe l'idea che quei
posti sarebbero stati dei fantastici
segnalibro nel libro degli inni appunto
ecco christine lagarde i fratelli wright
art fra i tre esempi di come una
passione personale possa fare la
differenza in termini di approccio al
lavoro anche in termini di creatività di
risoluzione dei problemi presenti quindi
di come la passione personale faccia la
differenza anche al lavoro
vediamo qualche esempio più vicino a noi
quello che vedete è un post recente di
linus dj e grande appassionato di corsa
che dice la corsa mi ha insegnato a non
avere paura di niente quando sono in
difficoltà al lavoro mi basta ricordarmi
che sono maratoneta per sentirmi più
forte
e poi ancora beh devio la nostra atleta
pala olimpica nel suo famoso selphy con
obama un self i ottenuto in barba a
qualunque protocollo che durante le cene
di stato non solo impedisce di fare
selphy col presidente ma addirittura di
avvicinarsi a lui
bene bene vi ho raccontato qualche
settimana fa che tempo che fa in che
modo ha ottenuto questo selphy lei ha
detto ho fatto come nella scherma ho
guardato dritto al bersaglio che era
obama disinteressandomi di ciò che
avveniva intorno per esempio delle
decine di finti camerieri in realtà
agenti segreti che cercavano gli
sbarrano il passo ho fatto come nella
scherma ha detto bebe vio perché lei ne
era consapevole ma allora quello che
andiamo raccontando una storia che vale
solo per le persone di successo per
quelli che ce l'hanno fatta e che magari
ripercorrono il loro successo
connettendo causa ed effetto no non è
una storia per di quella che voglio
raccontarvi io non sono la ricercatrice
ma quando ho cominciato a interessarmi
di queste connessioni e di questi
incroci
ho voluto condurre un'indagine e ho
iniziato dalle persone più vicini a me
ed ai miei colleghi per poi passare a
fare la stessa domanda e cioè se ci
fossero delle connessioni tra la
passione extralavorativa e il mondo del
lavoro a decine e poi centinaia di
persone diverse
appartenenti a gruppi sportivi club di
animazione culturale centri di teatro
amatoriale
insomma persona e con passione diverse
che naturalmente fanno lavori diversi mi
è venuta fuori una risposta quasi
unanime e cioè di quanto sia efficace
cercare di usare consapevolmente quelle
capacità che alleniamo dando vita alle
nostre passioni per poi sfruttarli al
nostro lavoro
vediamo qualche esempio quelle che
vedete sono le prove di volo di cinzia
appassionata di parapendio e
naturalmente professionista in
un'azienda che cosa supporta cincia del
parapendio in azienda
beh per esempio la pazienza nella
gestione delle attese che se nel
parapendio sono quelle del vento giusto
in azienda spesso sono quelli della
decisione che ti fa andare avanti
che cos'altro si porta in sé racconta ad
esempio del rispetto e della fiducia
nelle competenze diverse degli altri
nella capacità di relazionarsi con
persone molto diverse da lei perché
hanno insieme un obiettivo comune
e poi ancora la capacità di non prendere
un rimprovero sul personale rispetto
fiducia feedback cosa che fanno parte
della sua passione e anche della sua
vita al lavoro e poi valeri appassionata
attrice di teatro e anche grande
professionista che dice il teatro e
improvvisazione ed ascolto ascolto
perché tu puoi entrare in battuta solo
quando l'altro ti dà l'assist e
improvvisazione
perché devi intervenire quando ti rendi
conto che l'altro non ce la fa ora
pensate dice valeri in quanti casi
riesco ad usare l'improvvisazione e
l'ascolto al lavoro certo c'è qualcuno
che invece questa connessione non la
trova
sergio ad esempio aveva risposto che
secondo lui la preparazione fisica e
mentale che lo sport gli dona non hanno
attinenza col suo lavoro
lui dice li ho sempre visti come due
mondi distinti
ecco li ho sempre visti come due mondi
distinti e mancanza di connessione o in
mancanza di consapevolezza
in ogni caso
che mi ha colpito di più delle tante
risposte che arrivavano alla mia domanda
spesso era che qualcuno mi scrivesse non
ci avevo mai fatto caso però adesso che
me l'hai chiesto la domanda mi ha
stimolato la ricerca di questa
connessione e vado apposta pescare nelle
capacità che alleno nella mia passione
extra lavorativa per portarmela anche al
lavoro e questo funziona funziona perché
lo dicono anche i neuro scienziati che
la motivazione parte dall'interno parte
dalla nostra volontà di migliorare noi
stessi e il mondo che ci circonda perché
noi abbiamo il desiderio istintivo di
dirigere le nostre vite con autonomia e
fare qualcosa di significativo e
funziona se riusciamo a incrociare
queste competenze ad allacciare nuove
connessioni noi alla fine tutto questo
lo abbiamo chiamato match gli skills
perché a volte dare un nome ad un
fenomeno aiuta ad identificarlo a
focalizzarlo necci skills capacità che
si combinano capacità che si intrecciano
ma perché dovremmo impegnarci in questo
intreccio perché dovremmo impegnarci in
questa combinazione di capacità perché
l'essere umano evolve per aggiunte e non
per sostituzioni perché non possiamo
vivere due mondi distinti e separati
senza che entrambi perdano qualcosa
perchè se da piccolo mi piaceva la pasta
al sugo e adesso voglio solo il sushi
io non mi sono evoluto ho solo perso
qualcosa
il punto è riuscire ad amare entrambe le
cose e fare in modo che queste si
arricchiscano l'una con l'altra
perché impegnarci in questa combinazione
di skills perché l'armonia è un luogo da
esplorare
ed è lì che risiede l'equilibrio nel
sentirci un intero e non una serie di
frammenti
in affanno passano dall una all altra
vita da quella personale a quella
professionale dal piacere della passione
al dovere del lavoro l'essere umano da
sempre è in cerca sia del pane che delle
rose è stato provato che gli esseri
umani primitivi i nostri antenati
uscivano dalle caverne al sorgere del
sole rischiando la vita contro animali
ferocissimi per procurarsi il cibo ma è
stato provato che uscivano al sorgere
del sole dalle caverne rischiando la
vita anche per procurarsi i coralli per
fare le collane rischiavano la vita per
il pane rischiavano la vita allo stesso
modo per le rose e allora è nel destino
degli esseri umani vivere e lavorare
meglio se entrambi i bisogni sono
stimolati e soddisfatti perché noi siamo
un intero che se esce nella pienezza
purché ne siamo consapevoli e allora vi
chiedo a questo punto ci state già
pensando
qual è la vostra passione cosa che
sapete fare bene fuori dal lavoro che
potreste portarvi al lavoro avete già la
vostra risposta vi sentite forse di non
avere sufficienti interessi e attività
extralavorative vi voglio rassicurare è
una domanda che mi sono posto anch'io e
mi sono chiesta non essendo una donna né
sportiva né con particolari talenti
artistici quale fosse la mia passione
distintiva e poi l'ha individuata io
adoro chiacchierare si si proprio
chiacchierare parlare conversare è un
retaggio genetico
mio nonno francini un contadino
abruzzese che ha attraversato l'intero
secolo scorso nascendo agli inizi del
secolo e morendo nel
2001 era uno storyteller naturale il
cantore delle storie di famiglia
talmente curioso e appassionato della
parlata con le persone come diceva lui e
spesso alle apostrofava anche se erano
sconosciute tipicamente con una frase
che suonava più o meno così in dialetto
abruzzese viene la faccia conosciuta ma
ciro fi scusate ma portare una frase in
dialetto abruzzese a trento mi sembrava
doveroso di fatto alla frase significa
appunto ma tu mi sembra di conoscerti a
quale famiglia appartiene di quale ceppo
fai parte ma era una scusa una scusa per
parlare
ok allora una passione ereditata che
arriva da lontano ma che cosa ne ha
fatto consapevolmente al lavoro di
questa passione
qualche anno fa mi hanno chiesto di
cambiare lavoro e di passare ad
occuparmi di comunicazione interna è una
scelta che ho fatto di testa
però dovevamo metterci anche un po di
pancia e quindi ho cercato un luogo e
una teoria su cui fondare la nuova
funzione poteva sceglierne tante neo
scelta una anche quella della
facilitazione della progettazione
partecipata e si fonda di fatto su una
convinzione fondamentale e cioè che le
organizzazioni le aziende siano di fatto
reti di conversazioni informali e
generative ed è proprio sull'onda di
questa convinzione che nel 2012 per la
prima volta in un'azienda italiana
organizzato un board caffè per cos'è un
work caffè lo chiamano format di
tecnologia sociale ma in sostanza si
tratta di riunire attorno a dei tavoli
delle persone che conversano su un tema
che sta loro a cuore l'idea è che poiché
le idee più forti più efficaci non sono
quelle che si discutono in riunione ma
sono quelle che ci vengono la
macchinetta del caffè che cosa può
succedere se noi sfruttiamo quelli
informalità e riuniamo appositamente in
maniera guidata queste persone a parlare
del tema che sta loro a cuore che si
generano insieme idee molto più
innovative
una passione quella della conversazione
che nel work è si dice
nuova il mondo di sicuro ha mosso me
perché sono arrivata fino a roma fino al
cnr il consiglio nazionale delle
ricerche a parlare di word caffè e
naturalmente non ci sono andata da sola
perché per parlare di conversazioni come
minimo bisogna essere in due e quindi ci
siamo andate in due al cnr a roma dunque
parlare conversare potere della
consapevolezza non solo della
conversazione potere della passione che
a me ha fatto arrivare fino a qui fino
al the backs a trento e voi
fin dove vi farà volare la vostra
passione grazie
[Applauso]